Creed yes sir everything okay everything
is cool dude maybe a whole theme like a
wrap a wrap rhyme an urban thing an
urban yeah Stanley you want to help us
out with that Stanley Eartha Stanley not
me that's you come on Stanley put your
little game down and and join the group
no Stanley we're do having a little bra
alone we're having a brainstorm session
did I
stutter this was epic my cleanex shoes
were a huge Conversation Piece but man
my dogs are
barking my feet were so sweaty I can't
even build a coal you know what I'm
going to raise the
steaks you don't I want you to watch
this and I want you to burn this into
your
brains I think because this is an
image that I want you people to remember
for a long time to come whenever you
come into the office I want you to think
about this we don't need to yes we do
what I did
it thank you thank you thank you
see I'm still
here we're all still
here oh come on Dwight come on
man hey Meredith heading over to Poor
Richards yep cool cool cool you need a
ride
all right let's head
out sounds good do you have a coat yeah
okay can I have that no okay I am going
to count down from five five five four
I'm not kidding 3 two one give okay all
right here we go you are going to learn
to be more professional Luke that's what
you're going to do Luke crap what the
hell was that I had to do
that this scow it all right are we
good you're
okay he's
okay here we
go we search for the organs where's the
heart the precious heart I'm not feeling
well I need to sit down
sty are you
okay oh my
God oh my God you need somebody who who
understands your references who is
Kafkaesque I've never I don't know
him there's another woman and her name
is Italy and skydiving and Bungie
jumping okay so and I want kids and you
unfortunately have have already
completed that part of your journey down
there Michael it's not my decision it's
mother nature and mother has very strict
rules about
for till just keep pushing hold me I'm
right here crle my head I'm right here
I'm screaming I'm screaming I'm
screaming just push and breathe numb me
up I want anesthesia sh no you can't
have it it's too late no I don't want
natural you have to just push it out
okay keep
simulating okay do you have the Sharpie
keep simulating do you have the Sharpie
yes I do okay when the baby emerges mark
it secretly in a kind of a Mark that
only you can recognize and no baby
snatcher could ever copy ready
yes god wow what was on that butter
newborns are slippery Kevin great to see
you yeah thank you for the food oh and
also you
suck this is going to be a very good
year very good Jan is at home Jim is
back my protege Ryan is a corporate good
stuff um Andy and Dwight are rocking the
sales team I feel very
blessed how many windows are there in
New York City what critical thinking
comment on the spot question asked in an
interview okay uh let me think are you
counting Windows no how far aways the
sun uh 93 million
miles is it yeah and the diameter of the
Sun is 870,000 MIL which makes it 109
times wider than the earth and 333,000
times heavier than the earth shut up
about the sun shut up about the
sun okay well come on let's have an
auction let's do this we'll auction off
people like in the olden days hey I I
just want to say that I cannot believe
that I walked into a koi pond I mean
seriously walk
much oh I should wear a snorkel to the
next business meeting that I go to
Michael you know when you think about it
it's not all your fault I mean who puts
a c Pon in a Lobby well you know what
you're right Phyllis but I've been there
before I've seen that pond this is the
thing I am a world class is the
problem stop it now you're embarrassing
yourself it's okay we're having fun it's
actually not the first time I've been
embarrassed by a
pond in high school the girls volleyball
team always used to throw me into the
frozen lake four years in a
row was freezing no no no oh this is
even worse couple weeks ago I went to
get a new cell phone and I wanted one of
those packages where you have the five
you know the friends friends and family
thing and the guy was like your five
friends and I'm like uh I didn't even
know I I couldn't even think oh my God
it was so embarrassing oh was whoa I
don't even have Jan's cell phone number
and I hate her you won't give it to me I
was like oh well I guess I'm a loser a
[Music]
ler too far
God thanks a lot man thanks for the
advice
this is all I could
find eat it you don't have to do that
Kevin oh know I'm glad this is happening
thank you Michael why are you eating
stem first this is a new food for me how
else should I eat
it the other
way can I get some cheese whz or hollay
no no no cheese whz no holiday no
chocolate sauce just eat it come on here
comes the airplane there you go open
open into the hanger there you go y eat
it put it in your mouth and just eat it
take God I hate it I don't care whether
you hate it you said you do it eat it
eat it you're killing him
Michael I did it I did a cartwheel you
you when I said that I wanted to have
kids and you said that you wanted me to
have a vasectomy what did I do and then
when you said that you might want to
have kids and I wasn't so sure who had
this V reversed and then when you said
you definitely didn't want to have kids
who had to reverse back STP stap STI
stap STI stap I did okay you've no idea
the physical toll the three vasectomies
have on a
person and I bought this condo to fill
with children I am so sorry that I don't
want to bring kids into this screwed up
World okay but look if you want to have
kids then fine you win let's have a
kid
do you mean it you want to have a
kid hey M I talk to you privately for a
second about what your outfit what
what's wrong with my
outfit you you might consider pulling it
down a touch that's right trying to up
blow High bunch of prudes you know Oscar
is allowed to wear sandals but I'm not
allowed to wear open to it shoes is that
the how it goes Meredith your boob is
out fine Noth too far damn it Meredith
where are your pants it's casual
day
happy Toby Toby
Toby